so how do we know if a number is
divisible by 2 or 3 or 5 or 6 or 9 or 10
well let's start with 2 first so the way
that you know if a number is divisible
by 2 is if that last digit of the number
is even so an even number is like 0 2 4
6 or 8 so see if you had the number like
72 see how that ends in a 2 that means
that the whole number 72 can be divided
in half how about 4 3 how do you know if
a number is divisible by 3
well what you want to do is take a
number like 72 you add up the digits so
this would be like 7 plus 2 equals 9 if
the sum of the digits is divisible by 3
which in this case you can see that 9
divided by 3 that works out perfectly to
a round number right to an integer then
that means that the whole number is
going to be divisible by 3 the same rule
applies for 4 9 so for example if I had
72 again we can see 7 plus 2 equals 9 if
that sum of the digits is divisible by 9
and you get an integer then you know
that the whole number 72 is divisible by
9 so the rule for 3 & 9 is very similar
okay meaning that if the sum of the
digits is divisible by 3 the numbers
divisible by 3 at the sum of the digits
is divisible by 9 the number is
divisible by 9 we'll do some examples so
you can see how these work so for 5 now
what you want to do is you want to look
at the number if the last digit of the
number is a 0 or 5 then that means the
numbers divisible by 5 for 6 it has to
be divisible by 2 and 3 in order for it
to be divisible by 6 for 10 the digit
has the number has to end in a 0 for
that last digit okay so for example 800
is divisible by 10 because the last
digit is a 0 so see if you can do these
four examples now 315 750 158 and 189
let's start with 315 is it divisible by
2
well it doesn't end in an even number as
0 2 4 6 or 8 so it's not divisible by 2
how about 4 3 let's add up these digits
3 plus 1 is 4 plus 5 is 9 is 9 divisible
by 3 yes so that means 315 is divisible
by 3
is nine divisible by nine yes so that
means 315 it was a white eye
okay how about four five does it end in
a zero and a five yes so that means it's
divisible by five is it divisible by six
well it has to be divisible by two and
three to be divisible by six so it's not
divisible by six how about for ten does
it end in a zero no so it's not
divisible by 10 okay let's go to the
next one 750 is it divisible by two yes
because it's an even number it adds ends
in an even digit zero two four six or
eight is it divisible by three well 7
plus 5 is 12 plus 0 is 12 is 12 divided
by 3 yes so the number is divisible by 3
is 12 divisible by 9 no so that means
that 750 is not divisible by 9 does it
end in a 0 or a 5
yes so that means it's divisible by 5
matter of fact it ends in a zero so that
means it's divisible by 10 is it
divisible by 6 well it is divisible by 2
and 3 so that means that the number is
divisible by 6 and you've got it how
about for 158 well is it divisible by 2
looks like it ends in an even number so
that's divisible by 2 is it divisible by
3 let's see 1 plus 5 is 6 plus 8 is 14
is 14 divisible by 3
no is 14 too visible Valley 9 No so it
means that the number is not divisible
by 3 or 9 how about 4 5
well it doesn't end in a 0 or 5 so it's
not dozle by 5 is it divisible by 6 well
it's not divisible by 2 and 3 so it's
not divisible by 6 does it end in a zero
no so it's not divisible by 10 so it's
just a visible by 2 this one and the
last example 189 is it divisible by 2 no
because it doesn't end in an even number
is it divisible by 3 well it looks like
that the digits add up to 18 so that
means that it is due by 3 18 is also
divisible by 9 so that means that the
number is divisible by 9 does it end in
a zero or a five no so that means it's
not divisible by five is it divisible by
6 well it's not divisible by 2 and 3 so
it's not divisible by 6 and does it end
in a zero and no so it's not divisible
by 10 so in this case it's just going to
be 3 and 9 if you want to see more
pre-algebra topics
follow me over to that video right there
it's
giant pre-algebra review where we go
into more pre-algebra topics I'll see
over in that video